[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
in the next half now we'll see what's
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire
and they will be with us to remind you
right through until midnight for
extended news review
thank you and uh speak to you in a
moment because we've got the front pages
first
the eye leading with boris johnson
hinting at the possibility that the
final
loosening of restrictions on june the
21st
may not go ahead that's led to the
composer andrew lloyd webber threatening
to ignore the restrictions after june
the 21st
the guardian reports that care homes
warned the department of health and
social care
about the risks of discharging patients
from hospital
during the first wave without testing
them the financial times picks up on
president biden's expected lobbying of
the prime minister
to resolve issues surrounding
post-brexit protocols
with northern ireland the ongoing debate
over how
chilled meats like sausages or
chipolatas indeed will be made available
according to the protocols is the big
story for the star
metro reporting on a murder trial in
which the defendant
has claimed he made a pact with a demon
that he would win the lottery
if he took the lives of sisters and the
express leads on a row at the university
of oxford after a portrait of her
majesty
was taken down so enterprising
mcguire are here um well lots to talk
about um
president biden is uh is landed he's
heading off to cornwall
and of course the first bilateral talks
for the g7 summit
due to take place between president
biden and the uk prime minister
on thursday and if we look at the ft
andrew
um it might get his uh his knuckles
wrapped
well yeah i mean joe biden will be on
the side of ireland there's no doubt
about it on the
in the row over um the silly row frankly
over sausages and whether we can sell
mincemeat to
northern ireland now look currently
under the rules
uh chilled meats uh are regarded as agri
products so they have to
uh unless you're in within the european
union
they come under all sorts of intense
regulations because of
health and safety but um these rules are
intended to stop
dotty uh meat substances in places like
china
not blooming british sausages which if
we've been flogging the northern ireland
for
decades and decades so um there is um
this is being overzealous in my view on
the european union side
however they are within their rights to
say
uh sausages can't be sold because they
are because britney's outside
of the single market and the eu but it
does seem
a silly dispute uh and hopefully biden
being there big big big man present the
united states
maybe he could knock some heads together
yeah because ursula mondelez will be
there
the head of the european commission uh
macron will be there
um um merkel too
uh but the but it's it's but his first
talks will be with
with johnson and i think he wants to
have a good relationship with britain i
really do
i think the words he spoke at the uh are
the
the u.s air base when he arrived tonight
were quite encouraging
about old alliances and he had quite a
sharp words for russia and china
so um it could be quite it could be
difficult
in some ways tomorrow but i suspect
there'll be some progress
yes and just separately then from the
the good the issue of the good friday
agreement
uh the elements uh in which there there
will be progress is this idea of a new
transatlantic agreement between these
two nations kevin um the atlantic
charter
do you see you know fine times ahead or
will this overshadow
yeah well it's interesting the atlantic
charter that was uh
1941 churchill and roosevelt it's
charleston again casting himself
as uh as churchill as there's eight
areas on it
uh uh covered recovery is one climate
change in other trade deals defense
they're all there
i think i think boris johnson just likes
to to wave around bits of paper and uh
and make himself bigger than he than he
is i think
it's you you'd think he never knew his
good friend donald trump and biden knows
that in a way he's he's going to reel
johnson in and johnson's going to work
hard to be friendly
with biden after the trump experience
and
biden himself will publicly i think be
very friendly and
he knows for instance the um cop 26 the
big climate change conference is
hosted by the uk glasgow scotland later
in the year if it go
it goes ahead you need the uk uh as part
of that if you're going to make any
any progress but you know the ft picks
up what the times
uh highlighted earlier in the week this
question of northern ireland and biden
thinks brexit was a huge strategic era
quite frankly bonkers by uh by
great britain and northern ireland the
united kingdom and andrew says it's all
about sausages well it's a bit it's much
wider than sausages and
sausages are only a bit it's really
about a phrase you might know take back
control
and the european union wants to protect
its borders
just as the brexit brexiteers said the
uk would
afterwards and johnson put that border
down the irish sea
and he agreed that northern ireland
would effectively stay
in the in the customs union the single
mark that's essentially
broadly what what it is so you will have
checks on
on goods uh he agreed that and david
frost the brexit minister lord frost now
he described that deal which johnson
said was oven ready
he described it as an excellent deal not
so long ago and now he's trying to
unpick
his own deal and biden knows all this
he's not he's not daft on it
and so johnson will not get a
sympathetic hearing and at that summit
as well as well as the present european
commission you've got the heads of
france germany and italy so biden's
going to
side with the majority against johnson
and of course he
does consider himself irish you've got
but he's changed his family back there
so he's gonna be
much more sympathetic with ireland than
uh boris johnson was happy yeah i'd have
to talk to the canadians to get away
from the argument
with that with that list but um in terms
of the of this deal
um you know the questions today have
been put you know did they sign up to a
fudge knowingly did they not fully
understand
what do we do about it now can't we just
build the infrastructure to carry out
the checks
that the eu wants to see or do we sign
up to some sort of veterinary agreement
which would take
many of these issues away including
phishing issues you're shaking your head
because it's about take back control
so but how do you solve it is what i'm
asking well
um i i think i think their government
knew exactly what they were doing uh
they wanted to get brexit done they had
to get brexit done
uh it had been hanging over us for far
too long
they knew there would be complications
with northern ireland uh they knew that
they were going to be putting the border
down the irish sea
i suspect they didn't think the eu would
be as they intransigent i don't know why
they didn't think that because the eu
was always going to be
have a hissy fit the moment we left the
european union because they can't stand
it and they can't bear the thought
that anybody else might follow suit and
have the territory to leave because
quite a lot of countries are getting
very rested
with the eu's bureaucracy and the way
they got botched
the the vaccine roll out uh so but i
think they did know what was going to
happen and i think what will happen is
at some point we will um rip up the
northern ireland protocol
and start again and there'll be a major
route about it
uh because it's not working uh the
government knows it's not working
the new um uh leader of the dup the
rather odd
chap they've elected who thinks that the
world has only been
created for 2000 years he doesn't want
the protocol either so i suspect that
will happen
but it won't happen until well after the
g7 summit
yeah absolutely we'll see what happens
in whatever the communique is after the
after the meeting tomorrow um big pledge
from joe biden tonight as well
the fact that the u.s will donate 500
million fisa vaccine doses globally
brings us back to covert in this country
if we take a look at the eye then kevin
um the fact that cases are now rising as
fast as they did at the end of february
um hospitalizations seem to be going up
as well and the prime minister has
acknowledged that now ahead of the
decisions about june the 21st
yeah and uh i know that buying 500
million it doesn't solve the problem you
need 12 11 12 billion
uh doses to uh to uh vaccinate enough uh
or a minimum actually of uh of the globe
but now the i have picked up only on the
prime minister sounding
downbeat uh sometimes he can sound
downbeat not beaten the uh
in the same two minutes but he was more
downbeat
this time but they say the decision will
be taken on sunday
announced uh on monday what will happen
on the 21st
in england but picking up the rise in
number of people going into hospitals
but the number of deaths
are but there's still very small numbers
six
um and it's weather down the line uh
that increase in cases will lead to a
lot more hospitalizations a lot more
fatalities
as it did in waves one and two the big
difference in this wave of course
is vaccination more than half the
population has got both jobs uh
more than three quarters have got a
single job jab uh the nhs
is boasting quite rightly that more than
a million
young people signed up yesterday for
their job so
i don't think it's it i don't think it's
um cut and dried what will be announced
on monday for the following following
monday i still think it's
in in the balance and it's actually may
not be uh
you know all or nothing it may be that
some restrictions stay
and others are are released but it did
seem today
that uh the prime minister was was less
upbeat than he has been in the past
which is why the eye says he
was doubt he was down and many many
businesses suggest they are hiring
already
they're having to buy stock why wait
until sunday monday i know the argument
is
get the latest data to make the most
appropriate decision but
uh very difficult for businesses and
separately very difficult still for the
airlines
if we look at the metro stop stop go is
bonkers uh this is the ryanair boss
um o'leary who's among where all the
airlines are clearly furious about the
portugal decision
well it's been a shambles i think that
from the beginning to end our borders
policy has been a shambles from
start to finish we close the borders too
late uh
we close the borders with india we put
injury on the red list too late
uh and we send people to portugal we
encourage people to go to a football
match
uh chelsea versus whoever it was
and then um when people are on their
holiday bang
out of nowhere nowhere at all portugal
suddenly
is no longer on the green list and and
it leads to chaos and
it's caused great inconvenience now i
take the view
really you must be a bit mad to go on
holiday abroad at the moment because
it is so the government's policy is so
fluid it's so chaotic
it could change at any moment wherever
you think you're going on holiday
you could suddenly discover it goes from
green to red
so um but but mike o'leary is right
there airlines can make no plans
as quickly as they're selling flights
then then having to cancel them all
because people want to want refunds it's
a disaster for the aviation industry
and if we don't get this right soon i
think we could well see
one of our major flight carriers go
under
well i mean you know paris parish the
thought of that certainly
that was in an interview actually with
sky news i thought it was yesterday but
time moves very strangely in covet i
can't remember most of last year
no distinguishing features yeah honestly
no idea
stay there lots more to discuss
including what did the health secretary
know
about testing in care homes in the worst
days of the pandemic and when did he
know it
we will be talking about that next
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now andrew pierce
and kevin mcguire welcome back to both
of you
after dominic cummings so memorably gave
evidence to a joint session of the
the health and the science committees of
the house of commons
uh tomorrow it is the turn of matt
hancock uh which
is picked up already by the guardian
what should we be looking out for andrew
then
well the guardian have a story that some
of the care home providers had
written to hancock in march or emailed
him
warning him that people in hospital
should not be discharged from hospital
into care homes unless they've
absolutely been tested for
covid now we don't know where the
decision was taken
because we know a num many many people
who hadn't been tested
okay we were then put into care homes
and it had a devastating impact
on on people in care homes what we don't
know is
how involved matt hancock was in that
decision if he was involved but we'll
find out tomorrow because he'll have to
give evidence
now of course dominic cummings who said
come
that hancock should resign 15 or 20
times he accused him being a liar
he was he told the committee when he
gave evidence he would provide
written evidence to support it well the
committee's meeting tomorrow
he provided none of that written
evidence okay it's going to be it's
going to be
absolutely fascinating to hear what he
has to say many of the subjects of
course we know well um this of course
comes
as the contract awarding has been
challenged in the courts as well kevin
hasn't it
yeah i know absolutely court ruled a 560
000 pounds
contract to public first a uh a
marketing agency
uh was unlawful um they were they were
very close
to uh public first to dominic cummings
and also michael gore the cabinet office
minister and
this is kind of seems to be part of a
piece with this government
because uh it doesn't seem to have been
following any rules at all
and being wider accusations of the vip
vip lane tory donors friends children's
all getting contracts all doing rather
rather well
um and it is very very embarrassing you
understand the government had to act
quickly in an epidemic but it
did it really have to always seem to be
mates
chums pals neighbors
got the deals just it does stink a bit
and of course
you know this democracy is a conspiracy
against the public interest you don't
get good government
with just doing your mates favors yeah i
think that will certainly come up
tomorrow as well don't you
9 30 i think correct